In the Tenderloins' haste to be hilarious
and bust each other's chops in stunts and
punishments, the titular Impractical Jokers
can get, well… carried away.
The kooky antics of Q, Murr, Joe, and Sal
can and do veer into the unseemly, dangerous,
or even illegal, as these extreme examples
demonstrate.
A very special 2014 episode featured maybe
the most extreme punishment yet, and one that
would be hard to top, as it involved parties
outside of the Impractical Jokers foursome
as well as the government and what's likely
a great deal of paperwork.
Jenna Vulcano is a recurring Impractical Jokers
cast member, showing up whenever her brother
Sal needs to be made especially uncomfortable
by his cronies.
Her appearances usually involve staging some
kind of intimate encounter with the three
Jokers that aren't Sal.
The third season finale "Brother-in-Loss"
tops them all.
Sal lost the episode, and for his punishment
he had to watch, alongside his family and
friends, as Murr married Jenna.
That's really going above and beyond, and
the duo really did tie the knot, however briefly.
In fact, following this matrimonial episode,
Murr even tweeted:
"Yes I legally married Sal's sister, no joke.
And yes we annulled the marriage... after
the honeymoon night!"
Dental procedures are among life's most unpleasant
and potentially painful things, so even the
idea of delving into that world as part of
an otherwise innocuous and silly prank show
feels a bit beyond the pale.
And yet, on a 2014 episode of Impractical
Jokers, the Tenderloins made Murr, a man purported
to be their friend, submit to some unnecessary
and deeply uncomfortable oral treatment for
his punishment, having lost the episode.
Because the dental anesthetic of novocaine
is a powerful numbing agent, it's inherently
funny to listen to somebody try use the mouth
they cannot feel, not to mention try to eat
food.
Murr thus endured some novocaine shots and
then had to talk about a variety of foods
while also eating them.
"Braised beef…"
"Braised beef…" "...is brilliant."
"...is… braised b… braised beef is b…"
In short, he made a terrible mess.
The bit had long-lasting implications for
Murr, too.
Responding to an Impractical Jokers fan on
Twitter, Murr revealed that since the novocaine-related
punishment he's now, quote, "more sensitive
to it."
Complicating future dental surgeries now that's
suffering for one's art.
"The Permanent Punishment," the title of a
2014 Impractical Jokers episode, is also,
unfortunately for three Jokers, a spoiler.
In a prank involving attaching balloons onto
people just trying to grocery shop, Q, Murr,
and Sal in other words, everyone except Joe
fails, and gets their punishment.
For each guy it's a possibly eternal reminder
of that time they didn't succeed on their
silly reality show: a tattoo.
The Jokers go under the needle and ink to
receive the worst and dumbest tattoos this
side of Jackass.
Q's consists of a cat, along with the caption
"38.
Lives Alone.
Has 3 Cats."
That's mildly embarrassing, but not as ridiculous
and pointless as Murr's sweet body art depicting
a ferret skydiving.
Again, that's funny and humiliating for Murr,
but the hardest, weirdest, and silliest permanent
ink of all went onto poor Sal.
Because rules are rules and punishments must
be accepted on Impractical Jokers, he got
a thigh tattoo of musician, actor, and celebrity
offspring Jaden Smith.
And let's be honest it's not even a particularly
lifelike likeness of the rising star, either.
The Impractical Joker who loses this 2015
episode is once again Sal, and his co-stars
select a deceptively simple though no less
humiliating punishment.
The group heads to a New Jersey escape room
place called Exit Strategy and makes Sal go
through the experience get locked in a room
and solve riddles to get out with a group
of strangers.
But going through this mildly entertaining
group outing is not the entirety of the punishment
Sal has to pee his pants while locked in this
small, enclosed space with other people.
Urinating on oneself falls well outside of
the box of what's considered normal and acceptable
adult behavior, but Sal is faced with having
to fake a bathroom emergency, then make the
problem, well… rectify itself.
He literally starts to sweat, and the others
try to force his hand or bladder by playing
running water sounds through his earpiece.
Finally, Sal does what he has to do and urinates
in full view of everyone, in the escape room,
fully staining his lightly-colored khakis.
It so freaks out his unwitting escape room
companions that some scream and some can't
help but laugh.
But he still can't get out of the room until
a solution can be found, forcing pee-soaked
Sal to work in close contact with these strangers.
"That was awesome!"
"Don't — no, don't touch me!"
Murr and Joe lost a 2014 Impractical Jokers
episode, leaving them to a punishment called
"Strip High Five."
Both would stand in New York City's Union
Square and ask pedestrians for high fives.
Every time they're refused, the Joker must
remove an article of clothing, and the punishment
is over when one of them winds up completely
naked.
An onscreen graphic reveals that Sal and Q
almost replaced the punishment because they
thought getting high fives would be too easy
for Murr and Joe, and thus nobody would get
nude.
At first, it looks like that instinct was
correct, as the two easily get strangers to
slap their palms.
Then the goodwill of their fellow humans dries
up, and both Murr and Joe are forced to remove
more and more, with Joe losing both his shirt
and pants before his opponent.
Adding insult to injury, Murr's discarded
sweatshirt gets swiped by a rude stranger.
"Oh, no!
Jojo…"
"This is a rough one!"
The battle goes down to the wire, with both
guys left in their underwear and Murr ultimately
losing.
It takes him a good three minutes to steel
himself for the demeaning and illegal act
of exposing himself in front of the gathered
crowd.
And that's when New York City police arrive
and put an end to the shoot.
They didn't arrest anybody, but they most
certainly could have, as exposing one's private
parts on a street is quite illegal.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.